[Music]
we're down here at broadway and memorial
right in front of the manitoba
legislature where a few hundred people
have come out in support of the truck
convoy protest in ottawa people here
honking there's music playing as people
around the block here really in support
saying it's time to drop all vaccine
mandates across the country that's what
they're asking for their signs here
people saying end the tyranny others
saying it's time for this to go now
winnebay police have not blocked off any
roadways here there is just one on
assiniboine blocked off and they're
really saying they want to work with
protesters to make sure this continues
to be peaceful throughout the day
now inside the manitoba legislature
there's not really anyone in there today
because the politicians aren't sitting
until march and the memo went out asking
anyone who could to work from home today
because of this protest now it is
getting louder people have been out here
since 4am more people heading down here
and right now we have no idea how long
they plan to stay but someone said
they're staying until all mandates are
done brittany greenslade global news
winnipeg